FBI director Christopher Wray is
doubling down on the bureau's theory
behind the origins of covet 19. Ray says
a leak from a lab in China is the most
likely scenario despite insistence from
the White House that there's no
consensus on the cause it all comes as
Congress just held a rare prime time
hearing focused on threats from China
Scott McFarland has the story
it's a wave of crises involving China
they just shot it the Spy balloon shot
down worries of an invasion of Taiwan
whether it will provide lethal Aid to
Russia and growing probes into whether
kovid first leaked out of a Wuhan lab we
may call this a strategic competition
but it's not a polite tennis match a
newly formed U.S House select committee
on China warned the icy relations
between the U.S and China are entering a
deeper freeze what Xi Jinping sees is a
fleeting window of opportunity an
opportunity to move while he perceives
weakness in the United States CBS News
contributor and former Trump National
Security adviser H.R McMaster says there
are rising fears of China joining Russia
in an alliance in the war in Ukraine
does that extend the war yes it feeds
Putin's ATM it allows him to continue to
fund his war-making machine of policies
there will be our protesters briefly
interrupted the Tuesday night hearing
one with a sign China is not the enemy
meantime bipartisan scrutiny is also
growing over Tick-Tock and whether the
company's links to China could make it
vulnerable to propaganda despite a
spokesperson saying Tick-Tock is a U.S
company Bound by U.S law it gives the
Chinese Communist Party the ability to
manipulate our
social discourse or to amplify what tens
of millions of Americans see also last
night FBI director Chris Ray warned
China is blocking investigations into
the original source of covet the FBI has
for quite some time now assessed that
the origins of the pandemic are most
likely a potential lab incident in Wuhan
so here you're talking about a potential
leak
from a Chinese government-controlled lab
that killed millions of Americans
despite despite Rey's comments which
coincide with the latest findings of the
U.S energy Department the White House
emphasizes there's no consensus on the
origins of kovid and the investigation
continues Nate we will stay tuned to the
results of that investigation Scott
thank you